I release date and brand new cinematic  trailer have finally dropped the  starcraft 2 legacy of the void those of  you keen for the final chapter in the  Star Craft to saga will be able to pick  it up on November 10 and yes that is the  same day rise of the Tomb Raider and  full out full and so you might have some  tough decisions to make the release date  news was revealed during a special event  in LA today which was broadcast live on  twitch pre-orders for legacy of the void  recently opened and any of you keen to  get your money down early will receive  immediate access to the game 3 mission  prologue entitled whispers of a bolivian  the epic cinematic trailer is sure to  get starcraft fans in the mood as it  features epic battles dramatic narration  and some seriously massive beasties you  can check out the video in full on  gamespot now we go down in the comment  with your keen for this one and for all  the latest be sure to stay tuned against  like